can we? Can we really touch something?
So like, can I touch the camera?
The question of can we really touch something
is a great one.
Well let's say we have two electrons, I imagine
what we mean by touching is that they come
in and they actually physically touch.
Now one of the problems is an electron actually
has zero size, as far as we can tell, no volume.
So these would be infinitely scaled up.
So how do the electrons actually interact
with each other? Well they interact by exchanging
a particle. In the case of the electron it's
a photon that they exchange. So as they come
in a photon is passed from one to the other,
which changes the momentum of both of them
and pushes them off. So they never really
have to touch in order to interact with each
other, to exchange that particle and therefore
change their momentum and change directions,
experience a force. So I guess well what do
we mean by touching something? Every time
we touch something we are exchanging force-carrying
particles with it and that is touching.
If photons are both quanta of light and the
force carriers of the electromagnetic force,
does that mean that photons propagate magnetic
fields? And if so, why can't these photons
be seen?
Well that's because the photons are not real
photons they're virtual. Now this is a bit
of a problematic topic and one which I hope
to address in detail in a coming episode.
The basic idea with virtual particles is you
can't detect them. They are particles that
are there but you cannot directly detect them.
And they may not obey all of the laws that
we force real particles to adhere to. For
example there is the Einstein energy momentum
relation E squared equals m naught c squared,
squared, plus p squared c squared. And a virtual
particle doesn't necessarily need to obey
this equation. So you can't really detect
it because if you did it would have to be
a real particle and then you can't disobey
those equations like that. So this is something
that I'll delve into in a future episode.
Who are your top three most inspirational
scientists? I'm gonna take Einstein, Feynman,
and Tesla. Who are your most inspirational
scientists? Hey Derek, I guess a question
that's been on the minds of a lot of us for
a while now is who would win a chin-up competition
between you and Henry from MinutePhysics?
Now I wish this was a hypothetical but we
actually did this on the tube in London so
roll the tape.
I thought it would be Henry - that guy is
ripped!
So in school they say atoms want to have their
outer-most electron shells full, and will
willingly become ions in order to achieve
that. Well, why? And why do the shells have
the electron-holding capacities of 2,8,18,
32 and so on specifically?
Let me deal with the electron shells first.
See if you accept that electrons are not only
particles but also waves, then if they are
waves bounded to a nucleus that means that
they must be standing waves. So you may be
used to standing waves on a string - they
don't seem to move anywhere, they just wiggle
back and forth. Or you can have standing waves
in two dimensions on a plate. And what you
notice is that these standing waves take on
particular stable patterns so bound electrons
are just standing waves in three dimensions
and the mathematical solutions are called
the spherical harmonics. Because of the number
of stable configurations you can have with
growing amounts of angular momentum there
are different amounts of electrons which can
fit in every shell and that goes with Pauli's
exclusion principle which says "no two electrons
can have the same state," because they're
Fermions. So the whole point is what we're
looking at is standing electron waves and
there are only certain of them which are stable,
which are possible, which you can see in analogy
to say vibrations in a plate. So why do atoms
want the outer-most shell to be full? Well
this kind of minimises the energy state of
the whole system, so let's say you had two
atoms. if you actually removed the electron
off one atom and stuck it in the other so
that they both now had full shells, you would
find that the total energy is now lower than
it was before when the electrons were in their
previous configurations so the point is it's
just like a ball rolling down a hill. It's
that everything in nature "wants" to go to
the lowest energy state.
Why are the available frequencies of light
continuous? I keep hearing that atoms absorb
and emit photons of particular frequencies
which correspond to the energy levels of their
electrons. So where do all the other colors
come from?
OK it's true that atoms emit particular colours
due to electrons jumping between certain allowed
orbits around them but we get different frequencies
of light when these atoms bind up into molecules
or even solids or when they form plasmas because
then the charges are flying around all over
the place.
And in those cases, there's no longer these
clearly defined energy levels for the electrons
where they can jump and only produce certain
distinct colours. Then there are whole bands
of electron energy levels so we can get a
real range of colors. So that's what we see
from the sun or from hot solids, so that's
why we get a continuous range of frequencies
because the electron bands of energy allow
virtually any transition.
Derek, can I get a Veritasium shirt so I can
look nearly as cool as you?
It's funny you should mention that, Grey,
because Veritasium actually now has a T-shirt.
So if you want to get you can click on this
shirt. go ahead, click on it, or click on
the link in the description.
For your viewers interested in pursuing a
science career, what field do you think is
going to be the most exciting in the coming
centuries and why?
Look I can't say I know what fields of science
are going to be important in the coming centuries
but at least in the coming decades, I would
put my money on genetics. You know if you
think about the human genome project, that
took about ten years and a billion dollars
to sequence one human genome. And within the
next couple of years you should be able to
do it in a week for a hundred bucks. So the
pace of growth is simply extraordinary in
that field of science and that's why if I
were going into science now I might select
that kind of field. Have you every downloaded
a book from audible.com?
I have actually downloaded a book from audible.com
and I was listening to it on my most recent
trip, which was handy because I was on this
plane that didn't have an entertainment system
and I was also listening to it in the airport
and I found it really a good way to pass the
time. So if you're interested in downloading
audio books then you should probably try audible.com
And I have a book to recommend to you. It
is Richard Dawkins' book the Selfish Gene.
I read this a few years ago and I found it
really enlightening, but I have a bit of a
spoiler alert. Ah, well not really a spoiler,
more of a clarification on the title. I mean
it sounds like a book about a gene for being
selfish, but that's not what it's actually
about. What it's about is the fact that genes
themselves act in selfish ways and this I
found a kind of enlightening revelation because
if the genes are acting selfishly then the
organism can act altruistically if you get
what I mean. So if you haven't read that book
or listened to it you should definitely check
it out and if you want to download it for
free you can, just go to audible.com/veritasium
You know I really want to thank audible.com
for supporting me in this, my five hundred
thousand subscriber video. It really means
a lot to have their support so I can keep
going and hopefully get another five hundred
thousand.
One last question, Derek, I'd like to know
how, obeying the laws of physics, you ever
managed to put these jeans on.